[Music]
welcome back to the game on vegas 17 000
fans packing t-mobile arena to see if
manny pacquiao could cheat father time
as a 42 year old place was buzzy with
lots of our asian friends coming out to
see the party and early on
who could guess which fighter was the 42
year old
whose birthday is coming up in december
manny was hopping around throwing those
lightning quick jabs and combos but then
your dennis ugos had a powerful right
hand and is nearly half manny's age and
has started to show in the fifth round
as it rolled around you could get a
feeling that manny was slowing down lost
a little bit that pacquiao two-step
and all sorts of trouble as the action
continues commending the action
connecting with lefts and rights as the
fight continued on manny was showing his
age that's something nobody can cheat
and it catches up with everybody when
the dust settled it was ugos dominating
the final five rounds and winning a
unanimous decision in the future hall of
famer might retire many didn't want to
make any future predictions last night
on whether or not this is his last fight
but judging from post-fight comments it
could very very well be over for one of
the greatest fighters and ambassadors
the sport has ever seen
i did my best tonight but my best wasn't
good enough tonight
no excuses
i want to
i wanted to fight for the title in the
in the ring and tonight the champion is
named
august
i've done a lot for boxing and boxing
has done a lot for me
i look forward to spending time with my
family and thinking about my future in
boxing
i want to thank all my fans
that came to see me fight tonight
i want to thank
all of you
in the media for telling
[Music]
my story
about
what manny pacquiao has done in boxing
i can i can
in my heart i can i want to fight i want
to continue fight
but the thing is i have to consider also
my my my body i have to also a lot of
things
especially of my
works back to the philippines back to my
country
there's a lot of
there's a lot of things that i need to
accomplish and to help people
that's my mission
so it seems like that's always been
manny's mission helping other people
still ahead on game